maybe anybody you can kill someone with  your bare hands  so how would you do it random but not to  ruin them not be able to plan around it  I think that's the basic cry and it's  going classic gum you tie them up down  there while you sleep here again I need  your counsel have you ever even held a  knife before I think it looks like I  have done here wrap the pieces up  individually taking up summer quiet  can't give you the cat are you doing  personal you're making look so personal  phenomenally you're taking this way too  far I'm not doing this  put it down we have to be right can we  do it right please please do it right  the limit this but we did just tell him  and everything will be fine  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]